hello folks today I'm alone I gave my
son the rest the day off he's got some
other stuff to do and in anyways I
wanted to tie a couple loose ends from
yesterday and so I told him that he
could take the rest of the day off he's
the boss so and you tell the boss to
take the rest day off he does it doesn't
usually work in the opposite direction
but yeah it doesn't that anyways
yesterday we left off with a question or
a situation I said you know that you
more or less need to understand what
happened to past extinctions - you know
how they how they occurred and we've had
several big mass extinction in history
of life on Earth there were probably
many but there were what what are known
as the big five and I think we need to
understand what happened in those
extinctions before we can talk about the
extinction of man we have to have an
idea of you know how extinctions might
have happened and the question that was
left at the end of yesterday was that
you know you you know at least the way I
look at it you know all the extinctions
all mass extinctions happen in the same
way and you say well that's my son and
you know actually that quest you said
well that's a big assumption there you
know it's a quite a leap of faith and
I'm saying it's not I want to justify
that they must happen all in the same
way partly because just intuitively
mother nature does is not so
sophisticated she doesn't use one
mechanism per species or per
at that she she does it all in the same
way in fact if if if all these mass
extinctions involved because I'm gonna
show in a minute
involve the food chain it's very
unlikely that she would use different
mechanisms different agents for
different species different habitats
different temperatures whatever other
variable you can think of she does it
always the same way that's that's my gut
feeling but I'd like to do more than
just give you my gut feeling now I've
got some gut a beer gut I want to give
you a little more than that I want to
justify that to some degree and yes I
will be using evidence but the evidence
is not to convince you to persuade you
the evidence that I'm gonna bring into
into play here is to justify different
steps in the in the thinking process in
the in in how I reason this thing out
and again this this is for your benefit
I mean you're paying all those mighty
bucks to get an education here right so
this is a good time to get that
education at least to see a different
view of the world that you won't see
else out there so you know you won't
read it out there you'll see it here
okay so let me get going here weird what
is a mass extinction well mass
extinction is when a whole bunch of
animals die that's in general terms more
specifically it's the end of a food
chain one food chain dies disappears the
entire food chain disappears and a
parallel one that was not part of that
food chain continues okay that's a mass
extinction there's has never
been a mass extinction where all species
and animals die and all plants die that
that's never happened
and that's what you would expect from
asteroid hits and all this other stuff
in fact I showed a picture yesterday of
the entire earth burning nothing could
have been left alive on such an earth
and here we are you know the mammals you
know where were kings of the planet and
so no that never happened but that's
what the asteroid theory hypothesis
insinuates that if the entire earth was
burning all life came to an end and
that's not the case it's never been the
case and so that's one of the reasons I
also object against the asteroid
proposal but you know there's been
apparently five big mass extinctions and
they get this because they do an
analysis here I'm gonna show this this
is a graph that was published though
some time ago and it's very popular for
a person doing extinction or researching
extinction gives you an idea of how many
species disappeared in each of the major
events okay
and again there's big five there's a
sixth one happened around a conversion
in the about 270 million years ago in
the middle of the Permian that's also
being thrown in there now and ours would
be the sixth or the seventh if we
consider that conversion mass extinction
then ours would be the seven but again
I'm saying now we've had a lot more mass
extinctions and that we had extinctions
all the way to Cambrian but we're just
gonna look at these big five okay and
here they are you can see them here they
you've got the OS which is the
Ordovician Silurian you've got the late
devonian you've got the capitaine ian
that's the again the one that they say
occurred about 270 million years
ago right before the Permian extinction
and then you have the Triassic - when it
switched over to Jurassic and the last
big one which was the Cretaceous
tertiary KT or in this case Cretaceous
Paleogene extinction and ours is that
little H at the last near the end there
and that H is the holo seen extinction
that's the apparently the one that we
are experiencing these days in other
words there is an ongoing mass
extinction according to many observers
many theorists they say there there is
an extinction going on we're losing in a
very short geological period of time
we're losing lots of species and and
also individual animals so you know this
is one of the theories out there that we
are undergoing a sixth mass extinction
if we overlook the capitaine Ian 270
million years ago in the middle of the
Permian what causes do they do the
experts the paleontologists the
anthropologist of geologists and others
that look a little bit at the extinction
of past extinctions
what what causes they offer and here's a
summary of them this is out of the
Wikipedia you see that you had flood
basalts the sea level fall the you know
the decline in sea levels impact events
comets asteroids at sorting meteors
global cooling global warming global
warming specifically because it's a hot
topic today in the world among
politicians and among conservationists
and that's right up there among the the
most popular ones then you have one I
mentioned yesterday this clathrate gun
hypothesis got to do with the
release of methane you've got anoxic
events that's that the oceans are
starved of oxygen you have the from the
hydrogen sulfide again emissions from
the seas the oceanic overturn a nearby
nova or supernova or gamma-ray burst
probably from a supernova that's uh one
that's at least proposed for the
Ordovician it was sponsored by NASA so
it's got official backing you have the
geomagnetic reversal the Earth turns
either I've heard in two different ways
one is that the magnetic field of the
earth switches from north to south and
the other one at the earth itself turns
around and when that happens every
summer I think it's every twenty six
million years well then you have some
kind of event or that affects somehow
the animals on the surface of the earth
and you have also the final one plate
tectonics a couple other hypotheses
involving what is it disease and
competition that you know new species
out competes the old one
and then you have well you know other
comments there about the future
biosphere and so on and I guess that's
got to do more with us so these are in
general what people are proposing what
are what are these causes do any of them
in any way resemble what I'm proposing
well for sure not this is essentially
what I discussed yesterday these are the
causes that are offered by people such
as guy McPherson ease guy who who
chooses among these because they're all
environmentalists and these are all
environmental type events or mechanisms
let's go with the first one very quickly
let's see if we can run through them
this is the flood basalts he meant it
could have
produce dust and particulate aerosols
which inhibited photosynthesis and dust
cause food chains to collapse both on
land and at sea okay so that's that's
the mechanism that's being offered the
other one is that the these basalts
admitted sulfur oxides which were
precipitated at as acid rain and
poisoned many organisms in contributing
further to the collapse of food chains
and I want you to notice that in both
that first one in this one they talk
about food chains they mentioned the
food chains but it's something that
killed the food chains and it's
something which is environmental and so
the other issue I've got with this
especially the second one says you know
acid rain and poisoned many organisms
the question is why didn't it poison all
mechanisms you would think that acid
rain if it fell to the degree that it
killed a species why didn't just
continue killing all or several species
because we're talking about a mass
extinction here why did it kill all
species why would any species survive
and and this is one of the issues that
they always fail to address and the main
issue here the underlying issue is
selectivity they have no way of
explaining selectivity and they have
never explained selectivity the way they
get around it is by applying a different
mechanism per species and a different
one per habitat so you know the fish
weren't killed by the same mechanism
that the birds were killed or the
animals on land no the fish have to die
because the waters became too acid for
them and that's fine you know but then
why did all the fish die why did some
fish survive or some marine animals
survive under and others did not and the
same on land you know the issue is
selectivity and if you're going to use
one mechanism per species or per happy
that well then you're again eluding
the issue that you must address which is
selectivity and selectivity points to a
single mechanism and then the question
comes you know why do we have to have a
single mechanism why can't we have one
per species and that's when it gets
quite complicated and I think you have
to introduce a little bit of William
oakum in there you got to go with
Occam's rule and go with the simplest
and that's another underlying thing you
should keep in mind anyways the last one
is emitted carbon dioxide and thus
possibly causing sustained global
warming again this global warming is
because of what's going on today and
people are very hot on this topic you
know you have the Kyoto in Japan the
environmental gathering and they always
deal with you know global warming and
stuff like that and so this is a hot
topic and that's why it's always
mentioned you know among the causes but
the question is whether global warming
has any relevance whatsoever to
extinction
and again it's because the you know once
the dust in a particular aerosol is
dissipated you still have global warming
okay so that's the flood basalts and
again flood basalt is volcanic eruption
and what you have is lava with rocks and
whatever heated rocks igneous rocks and
anatta allegedly you know just created
such a monster in the atmosphere that
just killed the animals either either
through the blocking of the Sun or
precipitation as acid rain or emission
of carbon dioxide or other gases so
that's the first one then we go with a
sea level and you know sea level falls
so what does that have to do with
extinction well it could cause a marine
mass extinction and could disrupt
weather patterns enough to cause
extinctions on land but it doesn't
reduce the continental shelf area where
most of the animals are born in the
ocean impact those are very famous
we can't forget those at all because
impact does explain suddenness
spontaneity and that's what they like
about impacts and again we're talking
about large asteroid comet may be a
meteorite or whatever something from
from the sky came out of the sky Koreans
used to sing and that's essentially what
this is and so you have to kill animals
on both land and sea and the way you do
it by producing dust and particular
aerosols inhibiting photosynthesis
that's one mechanism the other one is
impacts on sulfur rich rocks one of the
theories especially for the Dino
extinction is that the comet I'm sorry
the asteroid fell on sulfur rich rocks
just you know the the Dinos were really
out of luck specifically the mosasaurs
the sea reptiles they were in deep
trouble because the impact the asteroid
hit sulfur rich rocks the sulfur went up
into the air and now it fell down as
acid rain which killed all the mosasaurs
otherwise they had no other mechanism to
kill them so again they're they're you
know we're having all these coincidences
that are just so convenient to explain
why you know some sea creatures died but
then again you can't explain the sock
tivity why some and not others and again
you see it mentions the collapse of food
chains you'll see quite a bit of that
and in fact all of them essentially
mention food chain either directly or
indirectly
and you know again the impact also could
call cause tsunamis and forest fires so
that's you know they have to destroy the
environment somehow to show that why the
animals died but then again they can't
explain the selectivity of it here is
the global cooling and we also have the
global warming and we're all more
familiar especially with global warming
in case of global cooling we have
sustained and significant global cool
could kill many polar and temperate
species and for others to migrate
towards the equator reduce the area
available for tropical species often
make the Earth's climate more arid on
average mainly by locking up more of the
planet's water in ice and snow and the
global warming well yeah we would have
the opposite effects expand the area
available for tropical species kill
temperate species or force them to
migrate towards the poles possibly cause
severe extinction of polar species often
make the Earth's climate wetter on
average and mainly by melting ice and
snow and thus increasing the volume of
the water cycle it might also cause
anoxic events in the oceans and there's
a little bit of a contradiction there
because the first you heard earlier one
of the proposals is that the sea levels
dropped you know and here they saying
the volume water increased because
there's a global warming and so you know
either the Seas dropped or they they
rose they can't be both ways and if as
they say that in all five mass
extinctions the big ones right the sea
levels are have been measured to have
fallen then global warming should be
removed from the list of at least the
five big mass extinctions but they throw
them in there anyways even though the
evidence that they collect you know
debunks it
so either the sea levels rise or they
fall and all five big mass extinctions
they say the sea levels dropped they
they went down so it's it's a question
that's got to do with the new species
that are being born near the shores in
shallow waters right and here they're
saying you know global warming but you
know melt the ice caps and suddenly you
have instead you know a rise of the
ocean levels and so you know again they
have all these contradictions and it's
like they don't pay attention to
their own evidence okay
another famous one when I discuss
yesterday methane clathrates in which
water molecules are the caged form on
continental shelves these clathrates
are likely to break up rapidly and
release the methane if the temperature
rises quickly or the pressure on them
drops quickly for example in response to
sudden global warming or a sudden drop
in sea level or even earthquakes methane
is a much more powerful greenhouse gas
than carbon dioxide
so a methane eruption clathrate gun
could cause rapid global warming again
we have or make it much more severe if
the eruption was itself caused by global
warming and again they use this term
global warming which is so popular today
among politicians and conservationists
because it's a it's a buzz term but it
turns out that you know the five big
mass extinctions have been measured to
have lower sea levels and I'm sure
they're gonna change that if they need
to accommodate global warming in some
way and another one is the anoxic events
that means the oceans are starglo of
oxygen our situation in which the middle
and even the upper layers of the ocean
become deficient or totally lacking in
oxygen their causes are complex and
controversial but all known instances
are associated with severe and sustained
global warming mostly caused by the
sustained massive volcanism so so we
have asteroids vulcanism global warming
those are the frontline theories and
every now and then they mention and in
passing you know that the food chain
collapsed so keep that in mind another
popular one I discussed that a little
bit yesterday and that's that three
authors there have proposed that during
the Permian Triassic extinction event
the warming also upset the ocean bout of
organic balance between
photosynthesizing plankton
and deepwater sulfate-reducing bacteria
causing massive emissions of what of
hydrogen sulfide which poisoned life on
both land and sea and severely weakened
the ozone layer exposing much of the
life that still remained to fatal levels
of UV radiation and the question again
if this is what happened why didn't kill
all of life why did all the plants
survive any plant survived when in they
all died waiting all animals and plants
died if this is this gargantuan
catastrophe accident of nature act of
God if this happened why didn't all
animals die why didn't all plants die
and again none of this none of these
mechanisms address selectivity they've
forgotten completely about this word
called selectivity about this issue next
one oceanic overturn is a disruption of
thermohaline circulation which lets
surface water which is more of saline
than deep water because of evaporation
sinks straight down bringing anoxic deep
water to the surface again it's a
question of how much air is available at
the surface of the waters and therefore
killing most of the oxygen breathing
organisms which inhabit the surface and
middle deaths one problem here is you
know a lot of fish and so on water
animals they deposit their eggs you know
in the in shallow waters and the
question is if this happened you know
again all these animals should have died
and I'm not sure that's the case I'm not
sure there's you know they can produce
any evidence of that it may occur either
at the beginning or the end of a
glaciation although an overturn at the
start of a glaciation is more dangerous
because the preceding Warm Period will
have created a larger volume of anoxic
water
again anoxic water why did every animal
die if they were starved of air nearby I
love these two
you know nearby gamma-ray bursts the
love that one it's got to be less than
six thousand light years away for it to
be powerful enough to destroy the earth
ozone there so we destroyed the ozone
layer now the sun's rays can penetrate
and kill what every animal and every
plant on earth right now they may never
address that issue
leaving organisms vulnerable to
ultraviolet radiation from the Sun gamma
ray are out gamma ray bursts are fairly
rare occurring only a few times in a
given galaxy per million years okay so
that's how they kind of justified the
main one that is being proposed for a
gamma-ray burst is your division
extinction they say that's what they
think happened again it was sponsored by
NASA why because NASA is concerned about
people paying attention to what happens
in outer space and here they had an
opportunity to do a little PR you know
and they say hey you know if we
stimulate these guys who are doing
research on extinction and we relate
that to the space to whatever happens
out there outside of the earth a lot of
people will probably pay more attention
to our own programs so I think this is
just the propaganda that's all it is
because it has no merit whatsoever
especially when you look at the the
mechanism the mechanism is that the
gamma ray simply blew off the Earth's
atmosphere and then somehow we recovered
it I don't know how far back after that
you know maybe a few years a few decades
but the issue is that they're saying
that it blew the entire what is it the
the smoke or the covering that the earth
has of atmosphere it just blew it out of
out of the earth and that to me is uh
sounds more like a cartoon I can't even
take it seriously
period
increased geomagnetic reversals will
weaken Earth's magnetic field long
enough to expose the atmosphere to the
solar winds causing oxygen ions to
escape the atmosphere in a rate
increased by three to four orders
resulting in a disastrous decrease in
oxygen okay so you can see what what all
the what all the papers that are being
written on extinction are all about
plate tectonics movement of the
continents into some configurations can
cause or contribute to extinctions in
several ways by initiating or ending ice
ages by changing ocean and wind currents
and thus altering the climate by opening
sea ways or land bridges which expose
previously isolated species to
competition for which they are poorly
adapted in other words the introduction
of new species into a different
environment simply because plate
tectonics the earth moved and now
animals can cross you know without a
visa
that's essentially what the people are
saying and then final ones here you have
others and one is disease or the other
one is a simple up you know one species
out competes the other because they have
a successful biological innovation but
all of the all have been rejected all of
these other hypotheses have been
rejected usually for one of the
following reasons
they require events or processes for
which there is no evidence they assume
mechanisms which are contrary to the
available evidence they are based on
other theories which have been rejected
or superseded and so they reject the
establishment rejects disease and
competition and so that's that's about
it that's the that's in a nutshell how
paleontologists geologists and all these
people who were interested in
extinctions that's how they view how
extinctions happen in the past okay and
and that's it
you can see that they're all chemically
leaning in a chemical direction they say
that there's been some lack of oxygen
there's been too many too much methane
in the air that affects the climate
there's been two months hydrogen
sulphide released it's all like we're
gonna kill you through heat through
burning through some gargantuan
catastrophe that killed many species and
since it's not selected the first
question is why did he kill all species
why did any species survive not only of
animals but also of plants and that's
that's the first problem we have for
this the other issue is that it doesn't
make room and this goes to the question
that you know with which I started and
that's the one asked by my son Adrian
yesterday at the end of the lecture
that's you know I'm making an assumption
a big leap of faith that all these
[Music]
extinctions the mass extinctions happen
in the same way and I only need one
mechanism I don't need one per species
and those are like leaps of faith right
but I'm saying there's something we can
guarantee listen to this saying
something we can guarantee what is that
and that is that if we we are standing
at the Cambrian line 542 million years
ago or so if we were standing there we
could predict that some plants are gonna
disappear periodically and I'm not
talking about just one species or even
many speech I'm talking of whole orders
entire families of species that
disappear why well they have to
disappear because first they intermarry
they they they in greed for millions of
years now you know what happens within
you know probably heard of the Amish
they've been inbreeding for the last 500
years and now they're starting having
you know kids with six fingers and
they're having genetic problems why
because it is in you probably heard also
the main son of the only son of the
Romanovs you know he was born with
hemophilia he his blood did not clot and
that's because he you know if you look
at all the all his cousins they all look
the same you know if you look at William
Germany who was a cousin to Nicky
Nicholas Romanov they were all grandsons
of Victoria Queen Victoria and you know
the the there was quite a bit of
intermarriage and I think we're all
aware that inbreeding causes problems in
the long run
and that's what happened to the plants
the plants have been had been or have
been inbreeding for a long time you you
know you see a thousand years that's
nothing but when you're talking about
millions and millions of years hundred
million years now you got a problem
because now you know these guys are
throwing pollen and just breeding and
having more of the same of the same of
the same of the same year after year
million of you after million of years
and after a while you know they wash out
their genes there is a genetic evolution
Andy and that evolution is always bad
and when those plants die the animals
that forge the relationship with those
plants that were born with those plans
and died with those plans all these
families of species from day one all the
way to the end the last you know they
have millions of years of adaptation to
those plants they cannot change at the
last moment because they've got it in
their blood they they they've been born
with that food and now this food is
disappearing because it's suffering its
own cycle and so what I'm saying here is
that if you stand at the beginning of
the Cambrian
540 million years ago you can predict
that periodically entire families of
plants are eventually gonna die and
they're gonna be replaced by new plants
and here's the graph here's the
synthesis of that I made this graph a
while back and I still stand by it and I
think it summarizes what I'm saying
quite well here we're looking at the big
picture very very very big picture we're
talking about millions of years here in
the first one we have from 415 to 300
million years ago that's 115 million
years second group is 300 to 200 million
years ago that's 100 million years and
again these are not scaled property
that's not the point
the point is that you know every hundred
million years or so we have new types of
plants dominate the planet they kick out
the old regime and they install
themselves they spread they cover the
planet and the old plants you know kind
of recede and they have fewer varieties
fewer quantities okay and a new plant
takes over and then that one is also
superseded by another one that comes
around that is born which is more
efficient perhaps more dynamic more
modern and kicks that other one also out
of the pedestal you know no longer King
and now we have a new king and and then
that one also gets kicked out by a new
one and what do we have here what we
have in the Devonian Carboniferous in
general terms right here we're talking
about very very general terms we're
saying we had the non vascular's and the
early vascular's and vascular means that
it can conduce water and nutrients
within the plant and the first plants
had no ability to do that they were very
very primitive plants and they just came
out of the water they they got on to
land in the Devonian and and even before
that in the Silurian all
the cooksonia came out and now we're
talking about here 400 and plus million
years ago and you know these plants came
out they were very primitive they the
original plants had no vascular tissue
and they were replaced by vascular
plants which were more efficient and
among those are all the others that came
after that yeah the ferns which you'll
see primarily in the permian-triassic
towards the end of the Carboniferous
they they were already becoming dominant
then those are replaced by the
gymnosperms in the Jurassic and
Cretaceous and these are the conifers
and those are replaced and remember
we're talking about these plants were
Kings they cover the entire planet and
now these plants are being replaced
today they've been replaced for the last
65 million years at least by the
angiosperms and those are the flowering
plants that we have today and they
include all kinds of you know stuff that
we eat including weeds that we don't eat
by the way okay that's important too
and here I have it in a different way
let's see if I can show this where's it
here it is
okay these are typical plants that just
just visually so that you can see what
has happened throughout time you have
cook Sonja that you know appeared more
than 400 million years ago it was a
first vascular plant it came out in the
Silurian and and and the Sonja type
plant it's a type of plant by the way it
just covered the land okay it just
covered the land that was the only
almost the only plant or the only type
of plant that existed and it was kicking
out the non vascular's and what came
next were you know horse tails and club
mosses in general terms they were
superseded eventually by the ferns
especially the seed ferns that took over
in the Permian and the Triassic one of
most popular plants in the permeant was
glossopteris the glossopteris day and
they they went extinct 252 million years
ago approximately they were replaced by
another seed fern called Dyke rhodium
and those lasted until the end of the
Triassic and again these were families
of plants and this is what the animals
ate because there was nothing else to
eat
this was their corn this was their wheat
this was their grapes and potatoes this
is what they ate every day for millions
of years and what happened you know the
die crow diems disappeared 200 million
years ago coincidentally with you know
all the ARCA stars what came next well
these plants again these plants existed
before they came into you know to be big
plants they already were developing
along you know 50 million or so years
earlier or more but the issue is now
they become the dominant plants what
plants become dominant in the Jurassic
the William Sonya is the cycads and
cycad like type of plants and that's
what they look like there you see it
there and they lasted to about 70
million years ago as far as I know the
cycad likes the bennett details as
they're known these plants died off
maybe 5 million years before the
Cretaceous and so a lot of animals that
depend on them started going extinct and
we're still sight cats there and when
those disappeared pretty much or their
forests depleted to to critical levels
that's when the dinosaurs disappeared
why because the herbivores had nothing
to eat that's what they ate and the
plants were gone and now they had
nothing to eat it's just that simple
and you also had conifers tall ones like
araucaria and you know pine trees of
different kinds and these were the
plants that dominated the landscape what
took over well the last group there the
angiosperms and they're the
Magnolia's the grass especially corn
wheat you know roses flowering plants
fruit giving plants and you know this
was poison to the dinosaurs I'm sure
that when they saw grasses covering the
land they didn't know what to do they
just stepped on it because they had no
use for grasses in fact we have no use
for normal grass we have used for other
grasses because wheat and corn are
grasses but we don't eat the typical
grass of what we call grass you know the
lawn what we mow with a lawn mower we
don't eat that grass and so we don't eat
all grasses and for sure the dinosaurs
had no use for any of these plants when
these plants dominated the landscape
that dinosaurs were gone
and here's more evidence and again the
point is not evidence but to show you
that the theory is consistent with with
what we see here this is known as the
Cretaceous terrestrial revolution it was
a four-year study and what they did was
look at what happened throughout the
Cretaceous and they say what took over
no doubt about it
were the angiosperms these are the
number of species and you can also
multiply that times quantity there were
more quantities of these plants and they
they cornered all the other plants
especially what what the dinosaurs ate
cycads conifers and other give no sperms
and ginkgos you know all those the only
ones that they probably did not eat were
ferns
I suspect that ferns were poisonous like
they are to us they were probably
poisonous or at least they were weeds as
far as the dinosaurs were concerned and
the ferns were really of the era what is
known as the mammal-like reptiles or
they're known as synapses or they're
known also as therapsids you've you've
got a whole bunch of the types of
animals that
were dominant throughout the Permian the
most famous is Dimetrodon he's got this
big sail back okay you know so if you've
seen this this lizard with a sail back
that's him and he lived in the you know
300 million years ago - 250 million
years that really he disappeared like
270 million years ago he lived like 20
30 million years and and throughout this
time what did they eat well they ate
ferns specifically seed ferns and those
were replaced by these cycads conifers
ginkgos and other gymnosperms and those
were replaced by the angiosperms at the
end of the Cretaceous and and that does
give you an idea of why the theory is
consistent the theory that I'm proposing
and it's a food-related
extinction mass extinction right it's a
food-related one it takes out a food
chain why because the primary production
disappears the animals that were used to
the conifers ginkgos and other
gymnosperms etcetera cycads could find
no longer find the big forest the the
you know the jungles and forests of the
types of plants they depended on and
when the herbivores died so did the so
did the carnivores and again the issue
here is that you know I mean put myself
back here so the issue here is that if
we were standing at the starting line of
the Cambrian 540 plus million years ago
we should be able to predict that
periodically there's gonna be some
plants that disappear some families have
turn orders I'm talking about you know
countless species here they're gonna
disappear that whole order is gonna
disappear for example all the seed ferns
they're gonna disappear and they're
gonna be replaced by what well they're
gonna be replaced by conifers
and then you have the era of conifers
and all the animals who establish a
relationship with conifers because
that's 90 percent of what's out there
and so all these animals carved niches
inside those plants and now comes the
you know the angiosperms the flowering
plants they displace the conifers not to
mention the ferns that they also get
kind of cornered out fewer species of
these lots of species of angiosperms
flowering plants but these are plants
that are weeds or poisonous to to the
dinosaurs they don't they don't eat that
stuff who eats that stuff well the
animals who grew with it when the
grasses were growing the little animals
us you know a little rats and so on
[Music]
purgatory yes and so on little animals
from the front from from the ancient
times they expanded with the grasses
with with all kinds of angiosperms that
were just developing they were small
plants yet they they who knows how small
they were you know but all these little
animals that's what they develop with
they carve Nisha's into different
angiosperms that were developing and
when these angiosperms started cornering
you know the the market when they
started pushing out all the conifers all
the specially the cycads and bennett
details the cycad likes the william
sonja's and so on
you know they've started pushing these
plants out and that's what the dinosaurs
ate and so you can see that that it is a
food-related extinction mass it a mass
extinction is a food-related extinction
and why is that important well it's
important for for a human extinction
because I'm saying that that's what's
gonna happen to us what's gonna have
this appears food so keep an eye on food
because that's what causes a mass
extinction and of course you know the
Disneyland economists as I call them
some of you
we're watching right now in fact they
say well bill we produce you know as
much food as we want you know food is
not an issue
it's not an issue and again as long as
there is money but once money disappears
I think we all can agree not that you
agree with my theory but I think you'll
agree that if money disappears if God
were to come with his magic wand and
make us all stop believing in money for
whatever cause you know he just weighs
this magic wand instead of making it
rain for 40 days and 40 nights this time
he comes with a different solution he
says I'm gonna make everybody become an
atheist and money nobody believes that
money anymore okay now I think you're
gonna agree with me that if that were
the case if money disappears there's no
incentive to produce or distribute food
and again we come back to food without
food for sure we die that's guaranteed
what you are not in agreement with me
probably with is that you know that
money's gonna disappear but if we
concede that if we concede that if we
can see that money disappears I think
you're gonna agree with me at least at
this on this point that if money
disappears there's no incentive to
produce or distribute food and we all
die a billion of us in a matter of weeks
or whatever amount of time the food we
have stored out there laughs which means
that you know it doesn't take too much
long after that for all of humanity to
go away and all of this happens in a
geologically Swift period of time that's
my theory you don't have to agree with
it I just want you to understand what
I'm saying I'm saying that if money
disappears and that's a big fight that
we're gonna have in Buenos Aires at the
conference for sure but if money were to
disappear okay if money if we stop
believing money we become atheists and
money with God we don't trust anymore
right the dollar bill then there's no
incentive to produce and distribute food
and if we do that for sure all of
humanity dies eight billion of us
we don't need any chemical reactions of
methane we don't need any chemical you
know anoxia or any bursts of gamma rays
from super no we don't need any of those
gargantuan Hollywood flashy effects to
kill humans they're very interesting you
know if you want to go watch a movie and
say oh look I saw a movie where you know
the supernova you know killed half of
mankind yeah that's great you know love
it but we're talking about real things
we're talking about putting our feet on
the ground and as you can see none of
the proposals that these people have for
causes for mechanisms have to anything
to do with genetics okay of either
plants or animals for that matter and
none of them have anything to do with
the overturning of the population period
pyramid you know of a species getting
older they don't believe that species
can grow old and we're an old species
humans are in old species because you
know we've since 6 1963 our population
pyramid has begun to overturn you know
we're producing fewer children that
means we have fewer and fewer young
people and more and more older people as
as time goes by so our population
pyramid has already overturned that's 50
years of it already
55 to be more accurate and and that's
irreversible once the population pyramid
overturns you never overturn it again
there's no way women in the cities are
gonna have ten children again in fact
more than likely they're not going to
have any so believe me the population
pyramid has overturned already it's
going to continue declining the the
population in other words the the birth
rate is going to decrease ever ever you
know more and more as time goes by and
that we can reach zero population growth
at some point and it's just going to
decline there more people are gonna die
then they're going to be born and and so
that's causes the extinction of man in a
different way through a population
pyramid inversion and I'm saying that a
mass extinction is gonna occur before
that why because when population drops
you won't have any you won't have as
much demand that's going to cause also a
problem on our economics what is supply
and demand curves what's the demand side
its population essentially its
population you can't have more and more
demand with fewer and fewer people you
can't have you company cannot expect to
sell more and more cars if there are
fewer and fewer people you cannot sell
more and more houses if there are fewer
and fewer people so those markets will
collapse
they will crash at some point when
population is saturated with whatever
they need cars the houses whatever and
that's when you start running into
trouble and that's another aspect of it
but again that's a long story to discuss
in Buenos Aires for sure over a couple
beers but the important thing now I'm
saying is is that an economic collapse
if we make money disappear for whatever
reason magic wand if you want for sure
we all die because no one's gonna
produce or distribute food and none of
these causes that I just read here
minute ago address that the other thing
they none of them address is what I said
at the beginning and that's that you
know you should be able to predict that
plants are gonna disappear periodically
and that's before man before we came
aboard
we're talking about just nature here the
plants are gonna suffer their cycles
they're gonna die and a new plant comes
up and replaces it another family of
plants or order of plants comes later
and what happens to the animals that
develop the relationship with those
plants they've gotta go so where do we
find anywhere on the internet I
challenge you
Wikipedia or anywhere you want on the
internet find me where there is a theory
that says that plants will periodically
disappear and the animals that force a
relationship with them disappear with
them
and that's a predictable thing it should
happen I mean in retrospect we went back
to the Cambrian we should expect that to
happen and there should be at least one
theory that mentions that and says look
the ones in the Carboniferous died
because you know the plants died because
it was predictable that they would die
and all the animals that force their
relationship with them died with them
there is no such Theory out on the
internet when I'm telling you it's
already predictable and if not you know
you have to challenge me on that one ok
well see you tomorrow hopefully with my
son I'll bring them back tomorrow ok and
we'll see you then bye bye